welcome back to las vegas now let's
focus on education in times of covid and
how children's learning abilities are
being affected by it mercedes talked to
an expert who's sharing some of the best
educational toys for kids take a look
all right we have charlene deloach here
she is the contributing editor at the
toy
insider so first of all you
are the toy expert but second of all
you're a mom so you kind of know what
you're talking about when it comes to
stuff like this
a little bit but i'm happy sort of to
share because i think the biggest
challenge for parents right now
is providing that multi-dimensional
approach to learning that schools
typically provide
so i think some of the things i'm going
to share today is going to help parents
provide that at home
so the first one is the v tech explore
and write activity desk
and it provides engaging content for the
younger kids ages two through five
with opportunities to really learn you
know reading and writing skills
color and shape recognition even you
know letters and numbers
even music and art with the included
easel and chalkboard
so they're going to have a lot of fun
while they're learning oh i love it okay
what else do you have
so we have 789
from play monster and how you play this
is you see
if you can add a subtract to the number
that's on a card pile
and see if you have a card that can be
played so for example if i have
this on the card pile and i have these
in my hands i have to add subtract to
see if i can play so obviously i got a
four plus one
five and i can play that card and what's
great about it is kids can play solo
so they can really work on their basic
math facts or they can
play with you know a few other friends
or family members
and really work on their math recall
that reminds me a little bit of uno but
with math because
exactly that's great okay what else so
we have
speak and spell from basic fun i
remember that from when i was a kid
right but now it's actually really
important to remember because it's a
great educational tool
kids can learn how to spell over 200
commonly misspelled words using various
play modes
and you know challenge modes and parents
love it because obviously the kids are
working on spelling
but kids love it because you know it's a
lot more fun than that spelling test on
fridays right
yes absolutely and i know some adults
who could probably practice their
selling one
okay what else do you have so gridley
games has a line of products called just
add and has everything you need for
activities
and experiments but you just add one
ingredient like
milk or water or what i'm showing today
because i think it's seasonally
appropriate
just add eggs and basically you just
have a variety of experiments and
activities with eggs
like there's even an eggshell mosaic and
egg experiments
so it's for kids five and up so the
younger ones you're probably going to
need to work with them on it
kids who are a little bit older can
basically use it as a substitute science
class
that does sound like a fun thing for the
whole family to do and still learn
at the same time exactly all right final
item these are great ideas so far i love
these charlene
so this is for older kids it's the hex
bug vex robotics series i'm showing the
catapult right now
but it really focuses on physics and
stem concepts
so this one for example has two builds
and
kids can not only build but learn
how to launch over you know projectiles
over 20 feet
so they're really working on like
precision and speed and distance
and really working on those physics and
stem concepts charlene
deloach thank you so much great ideas
and if you need any more
information go to our website las vegas
now